depuis quelques siècles une grande
extinction des animaux est en marche
pour la première fois des chercheurs ont
évalué comment les insectes étaient
affectés par cette crise
leur constat est alarmant ces petites
tentes est un piège à insectes
depuis 1989 les membres de la société
entomologique de krefeld en installe
dans de nombreuses réserves naturelles
en allemagne des insectes volants de
toutes tailles et de tous types
s'empêtre dans ses pièges les insectes
de capturer sont endormis par des
vapeurs d'alcool et tombe dans un
récipient
ils sont ensuite égoutter et peser
[Musique]
des chercheurs pour collaborer avec le
club amateur pour analyser les données
recueillies les résultats ont été
publiés en octobre dernier la chute de
la population d'insectes est
vertigineuse
au début de l'étude les entomologistes
capturés en moyenne 8 grammes d'insectes
par jour dans l'ensemble de leurs pièges
en 2016
les prises avait chuté à 2 grammes par
jour
en 27 ans la biomasse d'insectes volants
a diminué de 75 %
tout porte à croire que cette tendance
n'est pas limitée aux réserves
naturelles étudiée mais s'étend à toute
l'allemagne et même au delà
[Musique]
selon les observations des chercheurs
les changements climatiques ne sont pas
en cause en effet les températures ont
augmenté au cours de l'étude
ça aurait dû entraîner une hausse de la
population d'insectes
le coupable du déclin selon les auteurs
de l'étude serait plutôt
l'intensification de l'agriculture un
phénomène qu'on observe un peu partout
sur la planète les pesticides le
labourage à longueur d'année et l' usage
massif de fertilisants exercerait des
pressions néfastes sur les insectes
même si l'étude paru l'automne dernier a
été menée dans des réserves naturelles
la grande majorité des sites étudiés
étaient bordées de terres agricoles les
pratiques d'agriculture intensive
décimerait donc les populations
d'insectes sur place mais aussi au delà
des limites du champ de nombreux
spécialistes n'ont pas hésité à mettre
en cause les néonicotinoïdes la classe
d'insecticides la plus utilisée au monde
pulvériser sur les cultures et pendu au
sol ou enrobés autour des semences ces
composés contamine les cours d'eau où
ils peuvent s'attaquer aux phase
larvaire des insectes la mort en masse
des insectes représentent une sérieuse
menace pour l'ensemble des écosystèmes
de la planète
des insectes sont à la base de la chaîne
alimentaire et servent de repas aux
oiseaux amphibiens et chauve souris
qui subissent déjà les contrecoups de
l'épuisement de leur garde manger des
insectes sont aussi responsables de la
pollinisation des plantes à fleurs
sauvages et cultivées en fait 70 % des
fruits légumes et graines que nous
mangeons bénéficie de la pollinisation
par les insectes
certaines espèces comme le quant à nous
et les courges dépendent entièrement des
insectes pour leur reproduction
alors qu'on soupçonne l'agriculture
moderne de causer de déclin des insectes
c'est cette même activité qui pourrait
en subir les pires conséquences